vai botar todos
alex cuba no dia a todos é eu sinto é
que o bugre para aquelas nesta
conferência
como o miguel frio eu trabalho enfim
astronomia e crível falar aqui no
entanto um pouco sobre a terra
você ouve falar com ver que a nossa
terra é um planeta mesma maneira
vocês vão estar também estive aqui neste
planeta e o meu objetivo é convencer
você não comprar casa no outro sistema
solar
realmente bonita fantástico vocês vão
ver a primeira imagem a imagem foi feita
há 20 anos no dia 14 de fevereiro de
1990 foi obtida por uma sonda chamada
vai a jogo está a caminho neste momento
das estrelas e é preciso dar uma idéia a
fotografia mais distante nós temos da
terra e até essas mil e 400 milhões de
quilômetros
e eu gosto sempre de mostrá lá pra vocês
verem pequenez deste mundo
todos nós tudo que nós conhecemos tudo
que estamos aqui falar hoje nesta
conferência acontece online neste
pontinho
eu até consigo revela o portal diretório
é incrível mas é ali que nós vivemos
daquilo e reparem é fato uma coisa muito
pequena e nós eu vou gravar aqui uma
imagem positiva somos micróbios
a paraíba é eu trabalho de divulgação da
astronomia não faço mais nada e quando
falou comigo nas escolas como dizem seus
humildes são os micróbios mas digo isso
porque ainda são novos e pleno impor
limites para casa pelo menos bom pensar
que o microblog já não é nada mau mas
nós nem mícrons somos
para ele o objetivo da minha palestra
hoje da minha apresentação é tentar
design fica se com a secel
e vocês facto ver hoje que são seres
muito insignificante mas apesar de
sermos micróbios reparem que ele um
planeta mesma maneira e tem coisas muito
boas olhem eu vou agora aqui tentar
falar algumas coisas e esquece que a
terra facto tem e que sánchez finais
para a vida pode uma coisa que às vezes
nós enfim não falamos muito mas é o
tamanho certo fato até até o tamanho
certo o tamanho até a ver depois com
massa como matéria e é massa do fim na
gravilha e também temos a regra da fifa
na boca é muito mas é o ideal o nosso
corpo aliás como vocês podem imaginar
adaptou certa gravidade
aquelas tarefas resolvem a um dia vai
ver hotéis na lua em marto não se meta
nisso vocês lá vão ter problemas sobre
não viola a primeira para lá já está
prontinha
olha outra grande extinção
estamos a distância certa só eu mas na
frente vou desenvolver mais tópico mas
vocês vão ver que estamos mesmo fique
certo também
depois sob uma atmosfera maneira vamos
também falar um pouco mais à frente e
vocês vão ver com o facto da macaxeira é
excelente pra esse planeta que nós temos
inclinação certa uma coisa que daqui a
pouco vão falar que teve com estações do
ano
é eu lembro disso porque enfim é o tema
também deve cumprir uma velha anac nosso
tempo e portanto vocês vão ver a seguir
que vale a pena nós temos essa
inclinação depois olhe um campo
magnético
se nós não tivéssemos dito não estamos
cá vocês também vão ver mais à frente eu
vou desenvolver mais estas tema
uma boa maneira para ainda vai em que
ela está lá instalam em forma logo à
noite
é preciso dar uma idéia ela foi muito
importante por exemplo para a
estabilização que nosso lixo seja este
mês vamos imaginar um eixo de rotação
aqui nesta transviada manoel estava
porque temos uma lufada manhã entanto
ganhou uma lua muito insano é bonita
enfim todos nós estamos nela mas ela tem
um papel aqui não tem portanto eu vou
pegar então em 2 a 3 está previsto e
vamos falar ontem então sobre tabaco
óleo inclinação a inclinação face às
tensões
muita gente pensa que isto só é devido
ao facto da terra estar mais perto mais
gostou não é nada disso
a alemanha vem com inclinação por
exemplo nesta altura você imagina em
termos de que o solo vai ter mais um
esforço local até mais mexer no toque
inverno no hemisfério norte ce e
promissor e as pessoas devem custar até
ver com esta inclinação gostam que ver
depois olhe seis meses depois ela passa
desculpa para sair daquela posição
ok é o contrário vamos ter um branco em
cima e vai ficar embaixo vai dar mais
uma voltinha mais seis meses e as demais
estações e portanto se nós não
tivéssemos inclinação 9 primeira hora
nenhuma
abraão não havia pedra já abriga o
jornalista é graças à inclinação não é
graças à mané lula ó de agora uma
pequena coisa com estações brás e isso
tem a ver com a intervenção pois olha
outro aspecto importante da baguete que
elegerá para falar mas aí entrei na
terra
o nosso núcleo é externo ainda está
quente eo núcleo interno também mas o
estado tem partidos freitas e isso é o
que aparenta parece nós não tivessem se
partículas energéticas que o sol lança
todos os dias se chegavam sem qualquer
problema nossas polícias e tornava
impossível a vida
no entanto ainda vai em termos um
capacete e um dia vai acabar agora posso
dizer com de um núcleo vai deixar a
desejar o campo magnético
mas vocês vão estar nos pés cúbicos
a nossa recompensa depois olha para
puxar a maneira que vamos fazer porque
além obviamente de dar usarão o enem mas
por vezes olha há coisas que o espaço
não vê é bom termos macro chora e mais
olha eu já tinha contatos no sítio certo
tema imagens jogos temos claro e temos
bons vizinhos que também saiu porque
olha eu tenho ali representava um cometa
e vocês já agora temos aqui os planetas
o pelotão já não é o planeta agora quer
dizer não há planeta principal planta
não o que existe na mesma
eventualmente as pessoas perguntam mesmo
muitas vezes ameaça a todo vapor sei o
que aconteceu na vida profissional ela
não me sinto na rua é que me mudando já
com a inscrição agora mas vejam planetas
temos 8 e já agora está a escala o sol
não está em causa é martin está
escapando substituição do desta manhã a
nossa maneira
cartaxo local poucos dizia nós somos
mesmo muito pequenininho
nós aqui temos até um problema engraçado
vivemos num país pequeno um planeta
porque não é assim é pequeno não é
mas agora eu vou pôr o cometem movimento
e olha como está lendo subida lance
acaba com a subida da favela
olha ai pensei que eu vi que temos bons
vizinhos ainda vai gastar um ok agora eu
vou tirar júpiter olha vamos meu
trabalho comenta obra na câmara mas
vocês já devem iniciar pronto
espetacular também estava com um
problema nenhum não é bem assim olha os
dinossauros há 65 milhões de anos
constataram que o fato não era bem assim
não é aquele gás ea chatice nossa
parceira e tal
ainda bem que eu estou indo embora agora
sabem por quê porque assim o processo a
malta é praga foi uma coisa de deus
pereira embora parte há quem diga sim
aqui um otimista e disse as canelas
nosso time ruim né
e hoje estamos aqui mesmo no hotel mas
vocês têm mais calmas caldas - por trás
natal
ok a agenda é que eles foram embora
estamos ainda que só que nós temos o
impacto é uma das coisas que estão me
falando das vezes é raposa aconteceu
impacto qualquer dia um meteorito
qualquer coisa gigante pode dizer que a
inglaterra se isso acontecesse agora
posso dizer que é possível tentar isso
com 10 20 30 anos a distância atingindo
em que agora em 2010 é tratado no
estoque de terra sequer chega a cair em
vocês podem fazer mal ao momento para
entrar
e agora olha a terra a uma coisa
engraçada a deixou na altura certa
também fica tudo em nós nascemos na
altura certa
agora posso dizer que não há séculos e
séculos melhor para chegar aqui disse
caçá que há tanto vocês diz ponto
estamos numa época islã
mas reparem universo poético vamos dizer
como higuaín não é igual para todos que
o gênio e ela só não faz nada mas nós
seres humanos nós uma vez que ele não
somos oito só de hidrogênio e oxigênio
que rolou ontem né
como é que aparece para as estrelas
muito antes da terra ter surgido muito
anos ao ter surgido geraram a sil - e
então podiam carroll no oxigênio assalto
o ouro não é que estamos falando da
falta nós mas ouro e prata essas coisas
todas boas e mais tarde quando apareceu
o sol e quando apareceu a terra e outros
planetas
fomos apanhados santos não vai mexer nos
mesmo na altura certa da história do
universo quando já havia carbono
oxigênio estas coisas todas estão à
venda e é por isso que nós hoje estamos
cá porque mexemos facto nessa altura em
que já vi esse filme disciplinas e
ameaçados agora falando a compreensão da
vida que eu tenho aqui um pequeno sermão
sobre isso não sabe trabalhar em
soluções imediatas e reparei na
composição de uma pessoa humana
esta pessoa tem 70 quilos só querem ir
para 65 152 que os nosso corpo se gênio
neste caso o que eu penso gostei do óleo
um carro zero voto tal que faço tal se
fosse um pouquinho ordem de 6 sol o
hidrogênio foi produzido no início do
universo isto isto foi tudo feito de
estrelas
nós temos aqui hoje dentro do nosso
parente atos foram feitas dentro de
estrelas e que não porque passear há
milhões de anos
é fantástico somos primos delas é
incrível
e já agora é uma pequena parte vocês
aqui um caso e água
molinar e olha que o jato nos mandar por
isso claro e vamos contar boa daqui o
genitor eo centro naquela alimentar e
vocês vão comer um bife que tenha um
jogo nas drogas
a água ameaçava
eu só vocês algo mais livros
olha eu já tenho aqui composição do
corpo humano e para acabar mesmo
percebemos que já que estou aqui falamos
aqui muitas vezes as empresas negócios
eu pensei em ver em quanto é que vocês
valendo notar que olha o jantar
agora temos aqui o jato dos principais
da vida e vamos lá ver quanta cola-se
oxigênio maka angola olha mais uma vez o
destaque foi a 45 quilos a 0
não vai ter pouco jogou pouco olha só a
voz suave e pinheiros
[Aplausos]
ai que deve encantar as duas coisas que
é uma conclusão disse a primeira coisa
primeira conclusão
o jogador volta a inflação no mercado
500 mil euros por ronaldo é igual ao pai
sentiu mais que isso
outra coisa importante vocês quando
fizerem subida nunca meteu a bola sobrar
idéias nicolau na companhia para apanhar
e quinhentos e onze estão mais disse o
velho
mas olhem é concluído gostava de vos
factors a com os fantásticos nós temos
cá na terra foram factos dizendo strans
e agora reparem os gols aqui fato é
algumas coisas seus planetas facultasse
certo o tamanho certo enfim tudo aquilo
que nós tivermos dever é e também o
movimento no terminal tudo certo em
termos acertados nos concelhos do nosso
corpo humano atualmente é história nas
facturas final
nós só que não conhecemos mas nenhum
planeta é que por exemplo nos vemos lá
com estas críticas que não há em mais
lado nenhum
pode haver muitos planetas da galáxia
bola veio até há quem diga vida útil até
se calhar neste momento da nossa galáxia
nós revela que num planeta distante esta
hora da manhã estão lá esses atletas não
tenha pode acontecer mas nós não sabemos
disso sabemos que a viva e havia
inclusive uma coisa muito interessante
na vida da terra é e portanto este ponto
está de fato um planeta xuxa sinal e
essa é enfiar de final que eu fiquei
chata fato temos aqui quando sánchez se
nas primeiras a que liga o movimento e
finta mas sabemos um pouco isso que o
próprio universo nós vivemos está
preparado para ter vida
todas as leis físicas tudo que nós
conhecemos são feitas a vida da vida
parece que andou por aí alguém a pensar
nisto mas é um facto feitas a vida da
vida é mais gastar nós não sabemos
difícil a vida do regional
um facto aqui na terra temos de vida
temos evidência o gênio e temos facas da
competição muito interessantes de atos
que não foi notificado e que não por
isso obrigado pela vossa atenção e
espero que os gostos videojogo montanha
muitos ataques originados
as goteiras